まあ今日のテーマはね
心はもともと悪か善かということで
で この清善説 清悪説ということはどういうものかと
であの 立派にはね いろいろ説明は入りましたけど
まあいろんな他宗教やら哲学者のね
まあその清善清悪説についてはね
いろいろ意見がありますけど
まあなんか考えてみたらバカバカらしくなっちゃったんです
こんなアホな人を相手にするよりは
仏教の立場から説明した方がいいんじゃないかなと
というわけで 今日はブッダの言葉だけ
このテーマについてね
考えてみたいと思います
最初の言葉は このパバッセルミダンビッカレチッタン
タンチャコアーガントケヒウパッキレセヒウパッキリッタンということですね
これはアングトルニカに出てくるんです
この心は輝くものである
いわゆる無垢ということですね
それは客人により汚れているんだと
まあそんなに難しい言葉ではございませんね
まあ解説すると無茶難しくなりますけど
表面的にはまあ理解できる意味で十分だと思います
本来清らかであるはずの心が汚れているという意味なんですね
本来は清らかであるはず
これが汚れているんだと
現実的に生命の心は汚れているんです
だからこれはあの清らかであるはずですけどね
だから実態はそうじゃないっていう意味になるんですね
心が汚れているんだという
はい また次に同じ経典なんですけど
次の経典です バッサーミダンビッカレチッタン
タンチャコアーガントケヒウパッキレセウパッキリッタン
タンアッスッとワプトゥッジャノヤタハブータンナッパジャナアティ
タスマアッスッとワトワプトゥッジャナッサチッタバハワナナッティティワダミ
客人によって汚れて心は汚れていることは
真理を学んでいない一般人が如実に知らないので
その人には心の成長はありません
と これ あんまりにも明確にお釈迦様が断言的におっしゃるところなんですね
で こちら あの  これはちょっと見えない光なんですけど
見えますかね？私には見えませんね
あ え？このワダミという
このもうもうパーリローマ字で打っている
この最後の言葉ね あのワダミというのは
この私はというのは主語なんですね
あまりお釈迦様はこれ私という主語で語らないんですね
もう 第3人称で語るんですね
如来はということで 自我がなくなったんだからね
しかし 場合によって私はということをはっきりするんですね
その場合はかなり名言で
もうかなり世間には似たアイデアがないんだということはもうはっきりするんですね
だから責任持って語るんです
私が言いますと だからまあ
そこでも語る人としては
この言葉にはもう責任持ってます
批判は批判するならば批判を受けます
ブッダ直々という感じなんですね
だからこちらで言っているのは
この心は本来というかね
まあまあ清らかであるはず
心が汚れていますけど
この事実は一般人が知らないんだと
この如実に知らないということがとても大事なことなんですね
物事を如実に知るということは
特別に仏教用語で あの
まあ夏はね 昼寝しながら物事を考えるという意味じゃないんです
夢見ながら物事を考えるという意味じゃなくて
この如実っていうことは
この科学者が研究しているような感じで
観察しながらデータを取り出しながら立証しながら
もう証明しながら進んで
物事を知って持っていくことなんですね
どちらかというと この科学的なアプローチで真理に近寄っていくことなんですね
科学も一応完全ではないんだけど
もうギリギリのところまで頑張っているんですね
で 世の中の状況はどうなっているのかっていうことを調べるために
しかし 彼らがこの聖書を参考にはしませんし
人の話も参考にはしませんしね
客観的なデータを見て実験をして
モデルを作ったりして
で いろんなやり方で真理に達するんで
達した真理が他の科学者が他のところでもまた調べて調べて正しいかないかと探すことができますね
これはいくらか如実に知るということなんですね
そうすると誰でも同じ答えにね
達するはずなんですね
言ってることは本当のものであるならば
どこでどこで研究しても調べても同じ答えに達するはずなんですね
だから この問題もね 心の問題も
やっぱり如実如実に知る必要があります
しかし 一般人にはこれができないんだと
真理知らないんだと この場合
真理っていうのは 結局はこのお釈迦様が語られたものになりますから
それは誰も世の中では学ばないんだからね
あの仏教の国 仏教徒だからといったってもね
まあブッダの教えはしっかりと学んでいるかどうかっていうのはもう結局疑問なんですね
もう例えばタイとかはね
かなりかなり力を入れて仏教のことをね
タイの国民は頑張ってますけどね
仏教的仏教の知識があるかないかと聞き調べちゃうと
なんかどうか怪しいんですね
あの清浄説も性悪説も成り立つのではありませんということ
この教えからはそうなります
で 本来清らかであるならば
もう清浄説になりますね
しかし 客人によって汚れていますね
現実的には 調べても調べても心
汚れている心しか見つからないんですね
ですから 心が汚れているならば
もう性性悪説になっちゃうんですね
しかし ここは本来清らかであるはずでしたからね
だから性悪説は成り立ちませんし
清浄説も成り立ちません
なぜかというと そんな清らかであった経験は誰にもないんですね
生命にしてみれば一度しかもないんですね
一度さえも経験したことがないならば
科学的なデータにはなりません
全くも まあたとえで言えば
論理的に考えれば もう人間も哺乳類でしょうし
ヤギさんも哺乳類でしょうに
まあそんなにももともと同じ細胞も同じものからね
発生しちゃったんだからね
まあ人間にもこの角がね
鬼みたいに現れないっていうことはね
まあ断言は だけど ね 八木さんみたいにね
あるいはトナカイみたいにね
立派な角がね 我々ないって
もうありえないとかのは
ちょっと言いづらいんですよ
だから遺伝子持ってますからね
だからといって それが一つの事実だということは絶対できません
なぜならば 猿にもないし
人間にもいまだかつて一度でも角が生えてきたことはないんです
そんなようなことで 心がきれいであったというよね
その経験はないんです
そういうわけで この両方とも成り立たないんです
善であるはずの心は汚れているので
観察上悪ですが 理論上善なんですね
なんかややこしいんですよ
観察するとデータが全部悪で出てくるんですね
しかし この観察のある理論で観察するでしょうに
この理論上は清らかでありますなんですね
だから仮説はあるんだけど
出てくるデータがこの仮説はとは違うんですね
だからといって仮説は変えることはできないんです
理由はこれが仮説でもないんです
あるまたもっと深いところで
心は客人によって汚れていることは観察できます
今起こってないんだけど
これから起これるでしょうに
まあどうせ講演中 4 分の 1 行くとね
もうかなり怒っていると思いますけど
今は疲れてないんだけど
眠気がないんだけど あとまあ 15 分も経たないうちにまあ眠気も来るでしょうに
だからこれ客人でしょ？私の話がつまらないとかね
もう聞いていられないとかいろいろありますからね
それによって嫌になったり
眠気になったりとかしますね
だから 嫌になることも
眠くなることも 心が汚れたってわかるさなくなったんだからね
そういうわけで 皆様にも今ここででも
これはもう調べることはできるんですね
だから 客人によって心がごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ汚れているならば
この塵がない場合は汚れてないことになるでしょうに
だから これ以下の科学的な世界とちょっと違うことになってしまうんですね
科学の場合は 仮説を立てて
論理を立てて モデルを作って実験したら
結果が違うんだったら
仮説が間違っていると
で 仮説を変えたりするんですね
この場合はそれできないんですね
だって客人によって汚れることということは事実ですね
しかし 汚れてない瞬間っていうのはなかなか見当たらないんですね
アインシュタインのなんとか論理もありましてね
これがもう最近まで 証明することはできなかったんです
まあ何人かちょっとわかって覚えてないんだけど
何かなにかなんかもうあってね
まあ宇宙の中でね 何かあっても光はね
まあいろいろ曲がったりすることとかね
で わかったりして  彼の相対論はまあ見事に合ってるんだぞということになっちゃったんですね
そんなものなんですね
だからこれ アインシュタインの法則と同じく
なかなかデータが出てこないんだけど
理論は成り立ってます
が まあ仏教では悟りという境地がありますから
実験はあります だから実践してね
心の汚れを落としてみれば
強引に自分で もう客人
外から来る塵だからもう落とせるんですね
落としてみれば 自分で
あ なるほど 心は清らかやと自分で経験することはできるんですね
もうだからこの場合は
この仮説 データと全く違うデータが出ているんだけど
仮説は崩れません 現代科学の物質の話とこれっていうのは似ているんです
あの物質的なことをね
科学者が研究しますからね
もう彼らもやっぱりだいたい似ている方法でね
まあいろんな仮説を立てて
モデルを作って 研究して
調べて また数学も使って結論に達したり達したりする
そうやっていると また最後にね
クォンタムというね あのなんとか量子力学でしたっけ
で もう出てきて それからなかなか物理法則的で
法則で普通の数字計算でもう
できなくなってしまったりするんですね
不確定論が出てきちゃったんですね
で そこまで一応進んではあります
まだまだなんでこの不確定素粒子はこの観察できないんですかと確定した法則に従わないのか
ないのかっていうことはまだまだよくわかってないんですが
そこは仏教は全部きちっと説明して発見して終了しているんです
で まあ例えばね 物質もう学校の科学から考えると
まあ金やら銀やらいろんな元素とかね
説明するときは この清らかなものだと説明しますね
清らかではなくて 純度は１００だと
でも一度でも純度の１００の元素っていうのは存在したわけじゃないんです
水の分子一個見たって
水っていうのはH2Oでしょうね
決してH2Oだけの水がないんです
そこで実験室で作っても
水素と酸素のをね 合成して
電荷というものはありますからね
プラスかマイナスか いろいろ流行っちゃいますよ
だからH2Oプラスになっちゃうか H2O
マイナスになるかと こうわからないんですね
そこでプラスになる マイナスになることによってもものは違うんです
まあ水なんですけど だから科学的に一度でも純度の１００のものは観察したことがないんです
が 論理的には だから存在しないと言える？言えません
純度の１００の銀は存在しませんと
ありえないということは言えません
論理的にはあります ただ
現実的にはないだけなんです
昔よかった 買ってよかったなどは無駄話
はい それで実践論に入りますけど
よく日常生活の中で うちの子は昔はよかったと
今はちょっと暴れているんだよとかね
もうもう悲しがったりするんですね
こんなのは無駄話なんですね
買ってよかったっていうのはありえないんです
うちの子は小さい時からとてもいい子で
優しい子で 今はどうか分かりませんだけど
親に親を殴ったりしているんだよと
だからもう何とかして元に戻してくれませんかと
これは無理です その場合はもう嘘を言って人を騙すことだけ
宗教の仕事だから どこかの宗教に行くしかないんです
仏教では無理です 仏教は宗教じゃないんだからね
本当のことを言います
このカースト ことはなかったんだからね
それから頑張って元に戻るということもよくやっちゃいますね
時に精神的な場合は 精神的にうつになったり
やる気を失ったり いろいろことになっちゃうと
何とかして薬を出でもしてね
いろいろ工夫して じゃあ元に戻りましょうと
元の状況に これってありえないんです
でもそう思ってるんでしょ？皆様方
病気になったら 皆様方の希望がこの病気を治して元の健康状態に戻りたいってことでしょう
医者もそう思ってるんです
あれは勘違いです 元に戻れません
たとえ病気が治っても
それは現実です だから
この実験的にデータが出てこないことに足を引っ張られると大変困るんです
純度１００の金が欲しいと思っても困ります
もうどうしても必要であるならば
9.9 99.999のインゴット
なんていうのは金 何て言ったっけ
あれあれ インゴットに何か名前ありますね
延べ棒 金の延べ棒でも買っておくしかないんですよ
それでも手袋をはめて触らなくちゃいけないし
手で触ったらダメなんです
でもそれでそのままあると思う
ダメなんですよ やっぱり空気に触れないように置いておいても
素粒子がだんだんだんだんと通していくんです
もう意味がないんです
大量の素粒子がね ざっとそれを通していくんだから
ぶつかったり そちらにある素粒子を持っていったりとかね
はしますよ だからどんなものでも一度でも元に戻るということはないんです
逆に元って何なのかと
成り立たないんです ある時点を決めないとね
それ決められないでしょうに
だから現代 我々は自分の日常をね
こんな難しい理論よりも
どうやって人生に生かせるのかっていうことが大事なポイントですから
日常の生活の中で この元に戻るという思考をやめた方がいいんですね
あれは論理的ではありません
病気になったら元に戻りません
病気で治りますよ しかし
体は元に戻りません だから
小学生の時はすごく優しかった子がね
まあ二十歳になってから親を殴ることになっちゃったらね
元に戻れるってありえないでしょうに
どうやって元に戻せますかね？じゃあ肉体的なことはもうないことにしたっても
精神的にどうやって元に戻せますかね？まあ物質的には無理のはわかってるでしょうに
ありえないんです 心はあらゆることを経験して変わっているんです
じゃあできることは この怒ったり
もう腹が立ったり もうカッとなったりすることだけ
なんとか治療できます
しかし それで元に戻れません
私のところに来た場合も
若い方々はもうなんとか治せるものだったら治せますけど
一旦治した途端 元の人間じゃないんです
もう親が期待する人間ではなくなっちゃうんです
問題は解決していますよ
親に優しく接したり 親の面倒を見たり
乱暴なことをしない人間にはなります
ちゃんと仕事をする人間にはなりますが
元には戻れません それで現実的な状況は
心は悪のみということなんですね
悪を落とす努力をする
努力も現実的 具体的 効果的なんですね
それで仏教が語る悪を落としましょうということは
すごい具体的な話で もし心は本来悪であるならば
これは無理でしょう に
だから結構ややこしい理論になります
悪を落とせる もし本来悪であるならば落とせないはずなんです
もともとそういうふうにできているんだからね
落とすことはできないんですね
これは例えば人間の体がね
細胞が酸素 酸素で生きていますね
それは本来の姿なんですね
細胞には酸素が必要です
あの燃料を燃やすために
エネルギーのエネルギーを回すために
だから酸素がいらない状態は作れないんですね
呼吸しなくてもいいということにすることはできません
そうすると体が壊れちゃいますね
本来はそうできているんだからね
ですから あの 本来悪であるならば
悪を落とすことは不可能です
悪を犯す 落とせると あ
間違ったんでしたっけ？本来悪であるならば
悪を落とすことは不可能です
心は本来 だから悪ではないことになっちゃいますね
我々は現実的にもう怒っていても怒らないようにすることはできますし
欲が出てきても まあ欲を何とかして工夫して欲がないことにすることもできますから
だからそれは客人というね
外から来た邪魔者ということも見えてくる
だから仏教が強調するのは
この実践なんですね 悪を落とせますよと
汚れは落とせますよと
だからそれにそれを考えましょうと
このどうでもいいことを考えることは禁止なんです
今日はいつ言うか ちょっとまだ決まってないんだけど
今言います 本当は この清浄説
清悪説っていうのは仏教は扱わない問題なんです
無記という質問がありましたね
答え答えません アホやと
質問さえももうアホな質問やと
いうことで全然答えません
ですから本当は当時でこういう問題は起きてなかっただけで
今どちらかというと このもう西洋思考だから
西洋思考っていうのはそんなに古いものじゃないしね
もう世界一原始思考で頑張っているキリスト教を思考にしたっても
そんなに歴史は古いわけじゃないんですね
でものすごい もうキリストという人が亡くなっても
百五十年経ってから じわじわと現れた
人間あちこちでね 書き加えて作った教えですから
まあまあ その影響で我々は今
よくあれ鵜呑みにしていますね
設計デザインの人間の考えをね
知ってますかね アメリカのキリスト教の人々の三十三分の二は
ダーウィン説は否定するんだそうです
いまだにアダムとイブから完全な人間は突然現れたんだと
だから近親相姦なんですね
って言うんですかね うん
それが正しいんだと で
学校でも禁止するんです
進化論を教えることは
じゃあ拝んでください
アメリカに行こう 努力の成果によって初めて善を実感するんです
そこで我々は努力して
あっ 善っていうのはこういうものだと実感するものなんです
だから仏教の答えがすごいわかりやすいんです
ゴタゴタしないで頑張ってくださいと
元の状態はなんせやとかね
こんなのは頭イカれてる人以外は考えませんよと
時間の無駄やと 言えば火事になったらなぜ火事になったのかとね
調べるよりはもう火を消せと
それが仏教の立場なんですね
それで日本でよくやりますね
それからものすごい厳密に調べるんですね
火事の原因は警察が調べてるんですよと
あんなアホなことはあるのかいと
だって原因見つかったと
それでどうなる？どうにもならんでしょ
燃えた家は燃えちゃったんだから元に戻りませんね
だから火事の原因を調べることっていうのは無駄なんです
まあしかし 警察はこれなぜ調べるのかというと
この犯罪でも起きたのかっていうことはね
まあしっかりしたいんですね
何か怪しいことがあるとするならば
まあその人を追っかけていきますからね
だから別な目的なんです
先生が被害者のことを心配しているわけじゃないんです
はい 次のポイントに入ります
このコンシャスということはどういうことかと
まあ一応今日のテーマの答え出しましたね
どちらでも成り立たない
聖戦説も制約説も成り立ちません
で 誰か語っても無駄話
そんなことを考えるのは
まあ頭イカれてる証拠なんですね
あの如実ということっていうことは
現代日本語にするとありのままに知ることでしょ
ありのままに知らない
知ることしないっていうことは
頭イカれてるっていうことなんです
ずいぶんわかりやすく言えば
正しくもののことを考えてないんですね
客観的に ですからまあ
それはまあ一応答え そういう答えなんですね
人に良心があるから 心は善と悪の混じり合った性質だとする
これってこの哲学者ではなくて
よく一般の方々がよく言うんですね
皆様も大体その立場だと思いますね
まあ心っていうのは善も悪も混じってるでしょじゃないんですかとかね
まあ良心というものもあるんじゃないのかというね
気分があります どうですかね
本当のところ調べてみると
では これから調べてみます
これは矛盾です 良心説は
と言ってもわからないね
どこが矛盾ですかね 良心があるにも関わらず
なぜ悪を犯す犯すんですかね
悪いことしたらそれから悩むでしょ
あれは良心だと思ってるでしょ
あんなことやらなかった方がよかったなとか
悪いことしましたなとかね
反省したり後悔したりしますね
それは日本ではね かなり受けますよ
どんな罪を犯してでも
もう深くお詫びを申し上げれば大丈夫です
それからまたやっちゃえばいいんです
これはまあ日本ではもう一般的な文化的な感情ですね
本当に良心があるんだったらね
悪を犯しますかね それだったら良心と同時にすごい良心の反対はなんですかね
英語でも反対の言葉はないんです
だからないっていうことがね
みんな相当勘違いしているんですね
感謝するという言葉がありますけど
反対語がないんです おそらく日本語でもないでしょうね
この良心というのは怪しい感じですよ
これでは意味は通りません
これには反対の言葉はね
入れられますけどね だからといって意味は通りませんね
だから もともと人が罪を犯すんだから
良心良心とそんなことを言える立場じゃないんですね
だから良心が痛むではないだろうとか
あれやこれやと言っても
だから良心説はその場でもう矛盾になっているんです
良心で行うことは必ず
ん？善行為ですね 善が抜けてます
断言できません まあ問題ないんで
例えば腹ぐるぐで何かやることは問題ないんですよ
正直です 人を騙したいと思っていろんなからくりをやって騙してしまう場合は
その人は正直なことをやってます
で 良心に しかし問題はそこは OK です
やってくださいという意味じゃないんです
正直ということは OK なんです
良心でやっていることが必ず善になるのかと
世には悪がはるかに多いので
人の良心は大したことではありませんね
それから仏教は現実の話ですから
世の中を見る限り悪ばっかしなんですね
ばっかしって言ったっても
もうはるかに多いんですね
本当に完璧に清らかな人というのは見つかりっこはないんです
どう見ても まあちょこちょこといいことをしながら生きているだけ
あれちょこちょこっとなんですね
これが現実ですね ということは
生命全体的に見ると もう巨大な悪でできていますから
良心ってどこにあるんですかね
どこで機能していますかね
この良心というのは この二次的な現象なんですね
セカンダリプロダクションですね
何か別な品物を作ると出てくるもので
良心とは学んで身につくものです
これ学ぶんです したがって
人によって良心の中身も強弱も様々です
これ本当のことでしょ
良心はお母さんが教えてくれるんです
一番最初に   それからおばあさんもおじいさんもちょこちょこと教えてくれるんです
たまにお父さんも教えてくれるんです
それからも 遊んでいる仲間の中からも良心というものを学ぶんです
というわけで 人によって良心というのは変わるんです
一貫性もありません 良心には
欲 怒り 嫉妬 エゴなどは学ばなくてもあるので
悪が一次的現象なんです
だから お母ちゃんが子供に欲張る
欲張ってはいけないと教えるのであって
これかっこ悪いんだと
欲は教えたことはない
欲張ってください 教えたことはないんです
わがままになってくださいと教えたことはないんです
エゴイスティックになってくださいとお母さんが教える
教えません 怒ってくださいと一度でも皆さんは教えられたことはある？ないでしょうに
なのに怒るでしょう だから一時的な現象って何ですかね
欲 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ エゴなんですね
だから良心というのは二次的なんです
不幸の結果になる 悪行為はしやすいが
幸福をもたらす善行為はとてもしがたいんです
だから一時的感情が貪瞋痴なんです
エゴなんです だから一時的
いわゆる本来持っている感情で生活しやすいんです
だから欲張る 欲張るのはやりやすいんです
怒るのはもうものすごいちょろいんです
すぐ怒れますよ 教育は要りません
躾も要りません 道場も要りません
そういうことには あの野球のコーチもいましたね
もうものすごいカンカン怒る人が
誰でしたっけ？有名な人で
星野さんでした だから彼が一流の野球選手としてもう苦行修行したんです
が 持っていた性格はなんですかと
ちょっとしたことで怒るって
怒鳴って もう殴りに行くんです
悪い人ではないんだけど
まあただまあ性格はそういう性格
とても立派な方なんですけど
もう殴りにも行きましたからね
実際 プレイヤーとしていた時は
監督になってからも最悪
ちょっと何か気に入らないことを何かアンパイアのね
もう何か判断を間違ったら
もうかなり凶暴で殴りに行くんです
それはお母さんから学んだものですかね
ありえないでしょうね
お母さんの視点でも困っていることでしょうね
うちの子は本当に困っちゃったなとかね
なんでこんなことやるのかとかね
だから覚えておいてください
一時的現象と二次的現象というものは心にあります
この一時的現象はもう教えられても教えられなくてもやっちゃいます
そちらには道場は要りません
やっぱり良心を学ぶために
良い人間になるために
学校という道場があったり
会社という道場があったり
社会という道場があったり
そういうところで苦労しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
というわけで 罪 悪は起こしやすいんですね
それはブッダの言葉なんです
シュカーニアサードゥアットアヒタニチャ
ヤンウェーヒタンジェサードンチャタンウェーパラモドゥッカラン
あの 3 行に書きましたけど
これ 4 行のゲウタなんです
シュカーニアサードゥーニアットアヒタニチャ
ヤンウェーヒタンジェサードンチャタンウェーパラモドゥッカラン
意味は 我々の本能というものは
やってはいけない悪を簡単に犯せるようにできているのだという意味なんです
あれやこれやの直訳ではありません
直訳してみると スカラーニやりやすい
アサードゥーニ悪いこと
アットアヒターニチャ
自分に不幸を招くもの
自分を不幸に陥れることはやりやすい
ヤンウェーヒタンチャサードンチャ
何かが自分を幸福になる
それから良いことがあるとするならば
タンウェーそれがパラマドゥッカラン
最高というか とても最特に難しい
最高と言わないね その場合は
とってもというもうもう最も難しいというね
これが現実なんです だから決してこの宗教家いうことには騙されてはなりません
いつでも自分の心の状況を見てください
私たちにとって 誰に言ったっても
いいことをするのは難しい
難しい やる気が起こせないんですよ
悪いことになったったら
もうすぐやってしまうっていうのは
まあ育ててない心の普通の状況なんです
はい この良心の話 ここで一旦ストップします
良心の起源についてもうあと後ほど説明します
で 一旦ストップして別なテーマに入ります
生きるとは苦ですね 苦 show 体はブッダに説かれて
説かれたかな 聖なる真理第一です
説かれてではなくて 説かれた
聖なる真理第一です 真理発見しましたと
お釈迦様は堂々と言って
何を教えられたかというと
生きることは苦であると
これは異論が立たない現実であるとも説かれています
これで終わらないんです
お釈迦様は堂々とも堂々と獅子吼というライオンのことを吠えて言うんです
これは噂と言うんですね
で もういわゆるもう脅してるんです
間違いがあるとするならば言ってみろよと
私は完全に知り尽くしたんだから言ってますよと
ここまで大胆に喋るということは
歴史の中でブッダ一人だけです
たとえ神が出てきたってもね
間違いと言えませんよと
そこまで自信があって語っているんです
その立場から考えると
生きることは好むものではなく
捨てるべきものになるんですね
生きることは一貫して苦であるならば
ああ 生きていきたいなとかね
何としてでも生きていきたいって思うこと自体もバカバカらしくて
無知な行為になるんですね
だから正しくそれを理解するならば
生きるってことはアホくさくて
もうたまらないという気持ちにならなくちゃいけないんですね
こんなむちゃくちゃ頑張って
神経質で精神的に病気になるまで苦労して
もうアホらしくて 何やと
これはと 頑張っても苦
頑張らなくても苦でしょ
うん だったらやめちゃえばいいでしょうに
ということで 正しく来る結論は
生きることは好むものではなくて諦めるものであると
まあ私は捨てるという言葉はもうさっさと書いてしまったんだけど
専門用語は諦めるもの
諦めるという であるならば
本性は悪だとするはめになりますね
だからブッダの真理第一から考えてみると
心の本性は悪であると言わざるを得ないんです
が 言わないところは仏教なんです
はい それでは生きることは苦ということの説明にちょっといきます
感覚があるから生命というんですね
これは定義がないと喋れないんです
で あの 仏教は宗教とまるっきり関係ない違うものなんですね
で 宗教は定義しませんね
言葉に で 仏教と科学だけは言葉に定義するんです
定義して用語を使ってます
感覚がないものは物体
物質ですね 感覚がないもの
感覚があるものは生命と定義します
それから次のポイント
ヤンキンチヴェーデイタンタンドゥッカスミンティ
これ お釈迦様がね もうちらちらと教える一つの哲学用言葉で調べたんですけど
このこれは最初に説かれた場所っていうのはなかなかないんです
いろんな経典でこの引用を通して出てくるんですね
釈尊も引用するんです
私が言ったでしょ ヤンキンチヴェーデイタンサッバンタンドゥッカンという言葉はとかね
お坊さんたちもお釈迦様に説かれたことがありますけど
ヤンキンチヴェーデイタンサッバンタンドゥッカスミンティ
それでどういう意味でしょうかとか
そういう経典は結構あるんですね
あるんだけど お釈迦様は最初にこのヤンキンチヴェーデイタンサッバンタン
もう何言ってるかさっぱりわからないね
まあこれから説明します
で 最初にヤンキンチヴェーデイタンサッバンタンドゥッカスミンという言葉
説かれた経典というのはないんです
引用であるということは
かなり昔 かなり一般的に教えられたということなんですね
意味は感じるという何かがあるならば
あるとするならばなんですね
それらすべてを苦に属するのだと私が釈尊ですね
言いますと いわゆる感じることそのものが苦に属すると
何ですかね 意味は 生きているということは感覚があることなんです
物体なんですね 体が この物体の中で感覚があるんです
目 耳 鼻に感覚があります
細胞一個一個感覚持ってます
だから外のデータが触れるとすぐ反応するんです
それが物質反応じゃないんです
例えば自分の手をね 指で押すと物質的には下に潜るだけですね
指が それが物質的な反応ですね
しかし 感じるでしょ それは感覚の働きなんですね
だからスポンジを押すと
スポンジも指がちょっと中に潜ってしまいますね
それは物質的な反応で
それが宇宙物理の世界でどこでも起きていますね
それが計算もできます
ある決まってる正しい計算ができる方式によって動いてます
この反応が 地球の自転公転も
太陽の動きも 何でもかんでも
それでですね 科学者が物質を調べるところで
あら 素粒子を観察すると
何か数学計算に合わないものがあるんだと
不確定な現象が出ますよと
これって何なのかと と引っかかってはいるんです
これは私がずいぶん軽く説明します
この不確定論理は 瞑想指導するとき
今はあまり使わないんだけど
例えばゴキブリ 1匹を捕まっちゃう
で まあ中箱に入れて それからビー玉1つも置いておく
置いておいて 箱を開けて
ゴキブリをお尻をちょっと
指でね 指す 指で触ったらいいでしょうね
と同時にビー玉も転がっておく
計算できるのはどんな動きかと
ゴキブリはどんな反応するか分かったもんじゃないんです
ビー玉はどのように転がっているかという
これを分かりきってます
自分の期待と違って曲がっていったならば
その場所を調べたら曲がった理由が見えてくるんです
ゴキブリはどこで曲がっていくかとわからないんです
だからゴキブリの動きは計算には入りません
だから この不確定論理っていうのは常に世の中にあったんです
じゃあ科学者は最近ですね
発見したのは 例えば人間
物理学が正しければ 人間は立てないでしょ
こんなでっかい体をね
小さな足の面積で立つことはできないんです
できるならば ビシッとバランスを取っていなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そうじゃなくて 前に曲がることもできるし
後ろにこうすることもできるし
それは全部物理学に反対なんです
だから計算できないんです
だからずっとあった現実なんです
この不確定論は そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
そこは心という用語を使って仏教を説明するんです
科学はまだまだ心という用語は使ってないんです
まだ頑張って 心っていうのは物質的な反応であると
脳をくたくた調べたりして頑張ってます
で これ あの ちょっと教えてあげたらすぐわかりますから
言ったらあかんだから言わないんです
やっぱりああいう風にね
長い間苦労して苦労して
様々な壁にぶつかってぶつかって進んでもらわなきゃ
ちょっと良くないんです
あの世界は でも仏教の場合はね
そんなに不確定論っていうのはね
そんなに大したことじゃないんです
この処理を研究すると
なんでいろんな反応するのかというと
これは研究する人の気持ちによります
で これは科学的には認められること
認めるわけにはいきませんよ
自分が二つに分けたらって思ったんだから
そう大変なことになりますからね
アインシュタイン アインシュタインはね
神はなんて言いますか
ダイスはなんでしたっけ
ね サイコロは遊びしませんよとね
あの人は怪しいんだからね
神をあまり信仰してないしね
で それで言いたいのは
やっぱり物事はちゃんとした法則で起こりますよということなんですけど
では 量子力学で出てくるこの不確定の関数はどうするのかっていうことはね
はい まあそんな話はいいんです
で 感じることはイコール生きることなんです
生きるっていうことはそんなに大げさなことではなくて
我々はずっと感じているんですね
ミミズも感じています
ゴキブリも感じています
だからもう鳥たちは目がすごい
感覚が鋭いとかね 鼻 鼻の感覚は犬の場合鋭いとかね
そんなのはどうでもいいんだけど
感じるということはみんなにそれぞれあります
だから感じることが生きることです
感じるものはすべて苦というカテゴリーに入ります
現実的に苦楽 不苦不楽を認めるが
無常たるものは苦という理論ですね
だから たまに楽しみを感じる
苦しみを感じる どうでもいい感覚もあります
だから感覚そのものが 3つに分けられますね
それは経験的ですから
それは否定しません 楽だなとも感じたりするし
苦しいとも感じたりするし
まあ大したことはないとも感じたりしますからね
だから感覚は苦 楽 不苦不楽という 3つに分けてはいます
そこでドゥッカという 3つですね
これは現実の現実話で
しかし 感覚は瞬間で変わっちゃいますからね
何かに触れた感覚を生まれますから
大したことはないんです
楽しみを感じたっても
どうったことはない すぐ消えます
苦しみを感じたっても
どうったことない すぐ消えます
だからまあなんかどうでもいいということになっちゃうんです
苦であろうが楽であろうが
もう変わっちゃう 変わっちゃうし
もう意味がないと そこは苦という別な単語でお釈迦様は教えているんです
はい 次に生かされる衝動
生きるものは感じるのが苦です
ですから生きるとは感じること
感じることが苦というんです
苦を避けて楽を感じたいと努力する
だから苦は嫌なんです
例えば楽しみ感じても
あれ消えるのは嫌なんです
だから楽しみを感じる時でも不安があります
いつまでこの幸福は続くだろうかと
若者は結構それわかってますよ
楽しみのは今のうちやと
もうみんな大人よりすごいしっかりしていますよ
計算していますよ もうある日
なんか遊んでいる若者グループがね
喋っているのを聞いてたんですね
しっかりと計画通りに遊んでいるんですね
来年なんとか何何月になってくると
これこれしなくちゃいけないんだから
今年はこうやって これやって
来月はこうやって もうそれからバイトして金貯めて
再来年の 2月あたりで外国
あちらこちら行きたいと思っているとかね
それからなんとか何月になってくると
まあ就職を探して仕事に行きますと
だからもうさすがだなと思ったんです
あの短い時間だから 楽しみの楽しいのはしっかりと計算してやっているんですね
だから溺れるということはないんですね
まあたまにね あの失敗作も作品もありますからね
ダメになるケースもありますけど
まあほとんどはそうにはならないんです
それで この幸せはいつまで続くだろうかという不満がガクンと来るんですよ
一番最高の楽しい時は
苦しい時でも いつまでどんな苦しみは続くだろうかと
思って さらに苦しみを感じたりする
そういうわけで 生命が常に苦を感じるんだから
不安感じるんだから これなくそうなくそうとするんです
それが生きる努力なんです
気に入っている人と一緒になっても
ずっと一緒にいないで逃げる可能性はあります
だったら逃げられないようにどうしようかなと思わなくちゃいけないんですね
それでしっかり仕事をしたりとかね
なんとかもう 必要なね
もう収入を得たりとかね
家を作りましょうとかね
あんた好きな場所で作りませよとかね
あれこれやと計画立てて
それが生きることでしょ
奥さんもそれやっていろんな計画立てて生活するし
旦那さんもいろいろ計画立てて生活しているんですね
その計画立てて生活することが
この苦を避けたい 苦を避けたいということだけなんです
だから 手足が何かにぶつかったら
すぐもう手を戻しちゃうとかね
いうことをしますね それ
苦を避けることなんですね
何かに手足がぶつかり
ギュッて痛くなっちゃうと
すぐそこを手で触ったりしてマッサージしたりしてやっちゃうでしょうね
あれ 反応でやってるでしょ
考えてもないんですね
考える必要ないんです
あれ根本的なんです 苦を避けたいんです
薬も大嫌いだ 嫌も大嫌いだと言っていたっても
病気になると気持ちが変わります
そうすると あれはもう本能として出てくるんです
苦しみを避けたいと これが生かされる衝動です
だから日本でよく言いますね
神様のおかげで生かされているんだと
そんなことを言う人とは
私は挨拶もしたくないんです
正直なところ 話にならないんですね
あまりにも屁理屈で 何の証拠もないでしょ
神様に仏様に生かされたことが一度でも経験したことがある
なんでそんなもうまるっきり一度とも経験したことがない
ただ 皆様がなくても かつて一人の人間でも
そんな経験したことがあるならば
ないんですよ だから神話物語を書くんです
死んだ人を生き返してくれたとか
悪霊を退治してくれたとか
で 現実は調べると科学的に調べると
生きることって何やというと
すべての生命は苦から逃げてるだけ
だから苦があることが生かされている衝動なんです
だから皆様は皆様ではなくて
世の中にある人口の中でも60%ぐらい
人々は一生懸命お祈りしているでしょ
神という変な迷信に あれ苦しみを拝んでるんです
だから苦しみを拝んだり
苦しみを賛嘆したりするんだから
神を信じる国々っていうのはいつたっても苦しいばっかしなんです
幸せ 平和 ないんです アメリカはすごい幸せだと思っている
道で歩けませんよ どこでどこで殺されるかわからないんだから
日本の若者みたい あっちこっちもう一二時になろうがもうふさげて遊んでいる音
そんなことは向こうは無理
でも世界一すごいいい国でしょ
日本の方が徹底的に最高なんです
そこら辺でもういくら遊んでいても何のこともないんです
だから若者たちがね 自由に遊んでいる
あれカスと事件起こるカスと比較すると
もう本当にもうものすごいしょぼくないでしょうに
だから答えは簡単です
日本人の神の信仰というのはいい加減だからね
それよりは楽しいならやっちゃえっていうことで生きているんです
だからそれが正しいんです
それが犬猫もミミズも誰でも楽しいことならやりますという
これは本能の本能なんです
だから本能で生きているんだから
本当に幸せになっているんです
平和になっているんです
神に全部委託するともう最悪なんです
戦争を起こしちゃいます
イラン・イラク戦争はね
それからもうアフガニスタンとかね
それからパレスチナとイスラエルとかね
あれ全部神に人生委託しているんだからね
どこまで殺し合いやって終わるのかと
きりがないんです 殺しても構いません
だから だって神本人もみんな締め殺すんだから
最後 だから殺すことというのは悪にならないんですね
だから平和で生きることということを忘れているんです
現実を忘れているんです
人間での死にたくないんです
楽しみたいんです 野生の動物も死にたくはないんです
楽しみたいんです ということは
一貫して生命に苦を苦という感覚が注入されてではなくて
入っているんです これは宇宙の法則の中である物質以外のエネルギーなんです
だからそれは苦ですから
まあこれをなくそう なくそう
なくそうと で 頑張っていることは生きることなんです
楽の感覚にしがみつくことは渇愛と呼ぶんですね
だから我々は自然にこの楽しいことにしがみつくんですね
だから生きるとは何かと忘れちゃうんです
本当はろくなことじゃないんで
生きることで苦苦が回転するだけ
しかし そこを忘れちゃって楽しみを探そうではないかと頑張っているんです
それで楽しみにしがみつくんですね
このだからちょこっと楽しんだことがあったら
あの経験をもう一度 もう一度
ものすごくしがみつくんです
どこかで行くと ちょこっと女の子でもね
可愛い女の子とニコッと笑ったら
もうもう頭がいかれちゃって
それからストーカーまでなっちゃうんです
なんでかというと あのちょこっとした楽しみに徹底的にしがみついちゃったんです
それから妄想を働かすんですね
この人を守らなくちゃいけないんだ
この人に私以外は誰もいませんよとかね
で ストーカー行為する
で 病気になっちゃうんですね
その状況は 仏教では渇愛という専門用語で説明してあります
そのまま流れて生きることに何の意味も見出せません
だから ただそのまま流れたっても楽しみを探し方でしょ
何の意味もないんですね
ただ楽しみを探すだけが見つからない
見つかってもすぐあっという間に消えちゃう
たまに楽幸福を感じても
それも儚いものです はい
それではもう一度 根本的性質は何なのかと
善とも悪とも決定できるものではないんです
だから人生ってというのはね
根本的に善ですかね 悪ですかねとかね
この決定できないんですね
善を行い 悪を犯し生きてみても
その生きることが苦以外何でもありません
我々は善を行いますね
悪も犯しますね これは普通生き方でしょ
いいことも悪いこともして生活しているんです
これで 楽しくなったり
苦しくなったりはしますよ
だからといってどうってことないんです
全部儚いものなんです
仏教は特疑問は命は尊いですか？生きることの意味はなんですか？なんです
生前説ではないんです
あるいは善悪説じゃないんです
生きるとは何か 生きることに意味があるのかと
現実的なんですね 今生きてるんだから
これが何なのかと調べるんです
答えもあります 生きるとはこの連続なので無意味ですという答えなんです
何か目的あって生きているわけじゃないんです
生きることは尊いでも何でもないんです
ただ苦の連続なんです
だから無意味ですと堂々と言うんです
だから私に質問する時でも
生きている目的は何なのかと
何なのかと聞けば どんと答えます
何の目的もありませんと
ただ死んでないんだから生きてるだけやと
そこを大人に言っちゃうと
大人がぎゅうぎゅうと言いますけど
なんか尾っぽ踏まれた犬みたいにね
子供に言ってみたんですよ
中学生に やっぱり尾っぽはなかったんです
とんと言ったら あ そうですか
すぐすごくもう納得したような顔をして座りましたから
頭が悪くなるのは どんどん大人になる時なんです
中学生なんかはびっくりするほど頭がいいんです
苦を乗り越えるという目的を作れます
目的がないんだから作るんです
それが苦を乗り越えるという目的なんです
苦を 皆様が頑張っている
この楽を探すことじゃないんです
楽っていうのは観念的なことだから
苦っていうのは現実的だからね
それを乗り越えましょうと
はい じゃああの 途中でやめた良心に入ります
悪いことをすると批判を受けたり
他人から罰を受けたり
罰を怯えて逃げ隠れをしたりする経験がありますね
これはみんなにあると思います
悪いことしちゃうとまずいんですよ
やりたくてやってますけど
バレたらまずいんです
批判されます 罰を受ける羽目になります
逮捕されます すごいことになっちゃうんです
周りもこれこれをやるなかれと叱責します
悪いことする以前 周りからこれだけをやるなよ
これだけやるなよと言っています
言われています ある女の子が私に
これはまだ中学生でね
質問したんです 質問が
まあうちのおばあちゃんがいつでもいい人間になりなさいと言ってますよと
私はおばあちゃんのことすごく好きですけど
このいい人間とは何なのかとよくわからないんだと
それはどういうことかと説明してくださいと
ということは おばあちゃんは精一杯まとめて集約して
子供に 孫に覚えられるようにと
いい人間になってよと教えてますよ
子供はその知識を受けています
実行しようと思ったら
おばあちゃんが定義してないんですね
子供は頭がいいんだから
大人よりはね 定義ないことは実行できないんですね
意味がわからないものは
だから私に聞いたんですね
それで私もすばりと これこれこれこれやってくださいと
それでいい人間だよと
それでなんのことなのかよくわかりましたと
これから頑張りますと
それで話は終了 苦しみを受けたくないという切望によって行うべきこと
やめるべきことを微妙に感じるんです
皆様もそれを微妙に感じているんです
これはちょっとまずいやと
これならやった方がいいんだと感じてはいるんです
やるかやらないかは別なんです
しっかり頑張って勉強した方がいいんだよとわかっているでしょ
あんまりもう遊び吹かれた吹けてはならない
良くないなとわかっているでしょうに
だからこの何がやるべきか
何がやってはいけないのかということは
我々はこれを微妙に知っています
これはどうやって微妙に知っているかというと
この楽をなくしたいんですね
楽になりたいんですね
それで楽になる方法 苦が起こる方法っていうのはなんとなく知っています
欲しい品物は あった方が楽しいでしょ
じゃあ万引きしようと
まずいですよ それは万引きしようと
お金で買おうと 自分欲しいものは手に入りますよ
それ問題ないんです どちらかというと
金貯めて買うよりは万引きの方が早いんです
労働力も少ないんです
だから現代経済学で考えれば万引きやった方がいいんです
少ない労働力でたくさん結果が出しますからね
でもやらないでしょ 皆様は
まずいと知っています
欲しいものは手に入るというよりは
大変な不幸な結果になっちゃうんだぞと知っています
はい 良心というのはそんなもんなんです
それで良心が二次的に生まれます
苦を避けたい 楽になりたいという一時的な感情がありまして
この一時的な感情で 経験上どうすれば楽になるのか
どうすれば苦を避けることはできるのかと
そこを経験上学んでいくと良心が生まれてくるんです
だから良心というのは曖昧でいい加減で中途半端で
人によって違うんです
というわけで 良心には個性があります
生きる環境 育ち方 教育
文化 習慣によって良心が変わります
信仰する宗教によっても良心が変わります
生きている上での経験によって向上したり
退化したり 場合によって完全になくなったりもします
この良心というものは
生きている上でどんどん良心が向上する場合もあります
退化する場合もあります
それは現実でしょ いい人間が悪い人間になったりもするでしょ
勝手悪い人間がすごい素晴らしい人間にもなったりするでしょう
時々もう頭イカれたもう極悪犯罪者にもなったりするでしょ
良心は切り去ってなくなったりして
故に普遍性がない 共通性がない
良心には だから良心というのは
人間の本質を勉強する場合は
配慮するファクターではありません
あれは二次的な現象なんです
良心は生きる基準にならない
良心の声を聞いて それに従って生きてみても
社会との人との対立は避けられないんです
よく言いますね 英語でよく言いますけどね
リッスントゥーアコンシャスというね
良心の声を聞きなさいよと
そうするといい人間になりますよという
これはもう正しく物事を考えていない人々の言葉なんです
そんな自分の良心に 良心が言う通りに生活してしても
社会とぶつかります 喧嘩する羽目になる
なぜならば 良心というのは個性があるんです
自分の良心と他人の良心が違うんです
例えば自爆テロをやっている人々
あれ 良心でやっています
天国で特等席ありますよと
神のために人を殺しているんだよと真面目に信仰しているんです
だから しかし 世界はテロリストに対してはすごい厳しい態度をとってますね
だから決して名刺として職業はテロリストと出せませんね
どこかの外国に入る場合は
職業の欄にテロ行為ですと書いちゃうと
そのまま逮捕でしょ 本当は正直に本当のことを言っているのに
だから良心に従って生活するということはね
とんでもない話なんです
それぞれの良心が質違いなので
正義の味方という悪人になってしまいます
やがて人間が正義の味方というかぶるんですね
あれは自分の良心が正しいという意味なんです
だから世にこの正義の味方という言葉っていうのは
ものすごいとてつもない恐ろしい単語なんです
悪人以外は正義の味方にはなりません
重大なポイントは 良心は正か邪かよ
正しいか間違っているか
善か悪かはか 客観的に判断することはできません
良心は個性ですからね
良心は客観的な判断することはできなくなっているんです
はい これからはちょっと別な structural model というイッグエゴ supreme
これは私より皆様知っているでしょうね
一般人の心の状況について
仏教の説明はいくらかシグムンドフロイトの分析に似ています
カタカナではちょっと下手ですから
ローマ字使いました 普通はフロイド
フロイドと言っている人なんですね
かなり昔の人でね 赤ちゃんはイッグのみです
他人に無関心でプレッシャープリンシプルである楽しみたいというね
に従って生きるんです
赤ちゃん生まれた赤ちゃんを見るとイッグだけなんですね
わがままだけなんです
お母さんが寝ているかご飯を食べているし
一向に構わない 自分がお腹がすいたら泣く
料理していようか お風呂に入っていようか
もう気にしない 自分のこと
小さい時 歳頃になるとエゴが現れます
他人のことも気にしつつ
意の要求に応じる  歳 四歳になってくると
お母ちゃんがちょっと待ってねと言っちゃうと
はい 待ってますね だから歳の子
お腹がすいたと言ったら
ちょっと待ってね これ片付いてから作ってあげますよと言ったら
それはまあ大体分 分ぐらいは待ちます
赤ちゃんの時は待ちません
そこでエゴが入ってきて
いくらか他人のことも理解しようとする
歳からスーパーエゴが現れるんです
これ シグムンドフロイドの説明なんです
他人に教えられた倫理道徳感で成り立っています
このスーパーエゴはもうどんどん学んでいくんですね
歳 歳でこれやってはいけません
あれやったらかっこ悪いとか
もうよく知ってます 道徳が厳しいんですよ
小さな子供は アホなことばっかし以外は何もやってないんだけど
道徳観がえらい厳しいんです
エゴが人の主役で スーパーエゴがエゴスーパーエゴに非難されないように気をつけて
id の要求に応じることで人生は成り立っていますと
これはシグムンドフロイドの説明でしょ
なんか仏教と似てるでしょ
苦しみをなくそうと思って生きてるんですね
これ id なんです だからそこはもう社会から批判されないように
罰が受けられないように気をつけるでしょ
で 人のことも考えたりして
こんな程度で頑張っちゃえばいいんだとかね
結局は自分の喜び プレジャープリンシプルのためにスーッと生きてるんです
そこはいろんなバランスを取って生活しているんですね
だからそこはシグムンドフロイドはエゴ
スーパーエゴという 3つの単語を作って説明しています
引いてみると これは性悪説になりますけどね
だって自分のことしか考えてないんだからね
結局は  id ですからね
それでこの精神的な彼が医者だから
スーパーエゴがあんまり膨張したらダメやと
道徳観ですけど 危ないんです
良心とはスーパーエゴのことで
強くなりすぎると大変問題だとフロイドは言うんです
これ さらに勉強したい方々はインターネットでやりますからね
このオールサイトドットコムで出てきます
これ 心理学の学者が書いてる
大変な権威のあるホームページです
みんなプロです 書いてます
はい それになる前に ですから
この良心というのは当てにならないということを覚えておいてください
良心というのはスーパーエゴのことなんです
はい 次のポイント  取れますかね
もう時間もないね ９時まで
うん じゃあ休憩なしにさっといきます
で 本性説と時間経過 仏教は因縁論から輪廻という概念を紹介します
輪廻に基づくと 起源オリジナルコース
ファーストコース 原因ですね
は成り立たないんです
初めはこうだったということは成り立たないんです
輪廻っていう言葉だからね
回転ですからね 過去の現象は変わって
今の現象が起こり 今の現象が変わって次の現象になるという話です
だからオリジナルコース
初めの原因というのは成り立たないでしょ
初めは何かあったと言ったら
それはもっと前の何かがあって
今これがあるということなんです
だから初めは神がありきということはありえない
成り立たない あまりにもおかしい言葉なんです
初めはというのはありえないんです
したがって 生命に対して
性善説 性悪説は事実に考えない人の妄想になります
この性善説などは単純に妄想なんです
いい加減な主観主義的な思考なんです
で 西洋人がよく言うんですね
原因がなければ何も起こりませんでしょうにと
だからそれはわかりますよと
しかし 最初はその原因
誰が作ったんですかと
それは神でしょうにと
そうすると反論者が神は誰が作ったのかと聞かなくちゃあかんでしょ
だって原因なければ何も成り立たないという論理でしょ
そうするとその宗教家たちが
神には原因がないんだと堂々と言うんです
だったら神は存在しないという結論でしょ
それは認めません いい加減でしょうに
無視された要因 時間ということをね
みんな時間という要因を無視してますよ
科学はこれは考えますけど
宗教家が時間という要因はいい加減使ってないんですね
あの仏性 本覚 原罪などの概念は
時間という因子を忘れるか誤解しているんです
これ難しいんですから
飛ばしましょう で 結構難しいんです
ファーストコース オリジナルコースを推測しているんです
時間を無視してファーストコースということ
オリジナルコースはコースというのは原因でね
ファーストは知ってますね
考えるんですね 頭では無限を理解できないので
とりあえず起源因を推測して手を打つんです
例えばニワトリが先か卵先かと考えれば考えきれないでしょう
で 鶏がいたんだから卵でしょ
で 鶏が卵をいたんだから鶏だから
また卵あって この卵は鶏がなければ成り立たないしね
その鶏が卵なければ成り立たないし
これいくら考えても終点に行かないね
で それで手を打つんですね
いつか何時何分で最初に鶏が現れたとかね
アダム論がそうやってできたものなんです
鶏には使ってないんだけど
その馬鹿どもたちは平気で人間に使っているんです
で 私 人間が人間の両親がないといないでしょうに
その人間両親二人がまた人間四人がいなかったらいないでしょうに
その四人がまた八人がいなかったらいないでしょうに
計算逆計算してください
ちょっと二千 千五百年ぐらい遡っちゃうと
地球上ぎゅうぎゅうと人間いることになっちゃうんです
もっと遡っちゃうと もう肩ならもうこうやって人間がいなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
でしょ どこかで手を打たないと
手を打つんです 最初は一人もいなかった
それで神がアダムとイワ作りましたと
そこから人間がダラダラダラダラと現れてきたんだと
それだったら人間一種類でなければ
どうやってオーストロロイドとかね
有利でしたっけ？高軽減ですね
私たち 皆様はモンゴロイドですね
どうやってその３種類
ニグロイドですね どうやってニグロイドで
皆様はモンゴロイドで我々何でしたっけ？忘れちゃった
この３種類ですね どうやってこれ現れたんですかね？アダム３人いたんですかね
そこまで考えてなかったんで
原始時代の思考だからね
立証できない概念なので
妄想と感情以外何でもありません
そんなのは はい 無限についてお釈迦様は語ります
無限というのは理解できないんです
アナマトゴーアナマタッゴーヤンビッグエサンサーロフッバコーネパンニャーエティアヴィッジャーニーヴァラナーナンサッターナンタンナーサンヨージャーナーナンサンダービタンサンサラタン
比丘たちよ 輪廻は不始点でありますと
なんか変な単語ですね
わざと入れたんです 始点はなしと
無明という蓋に覆われて覆われて
渇愛に束縛されて さもよって輪廻をする生命には
視点を定めることは不可能でありますと
だって原因から生まれるんだから
その原因はまた原因から生まれるんだから
だからスタート時点がなくなっちゃうんです
無限になっちゃうんですね
それは認識することは不可能です
これは不可知ということになるんですね
それから無明の視点も不可知ですね
プリマービッカレコートネパンニャーエティアヴィッジャーヤイトープッデアヴィッジャーナーホーシアタパッチャサンバヴァーティーティエーワンチェタンビクエウ
ッチャティアタチャパナパンニャーエティイダッパッチャアヴィッジャーティ
これは仏教の中で もう極極端に難しいところですよ
だからあんまり説法にも使いません
難しすぎちゃって もう今日はしょうがなく使う羽目になっちゃったんですけど
ここから無明が現れた
以前なかったという無明の視点も定めることは不可能ですと
無明で生命輪廻転生するんだっていうことは仏教の話です
無知によって輪廻転生するんだと
しかし 無知はいつ始めたかということはもう不可知なんですね
しかし 無明 明確なことは
因縁によって無明が起こるということですと
無明にも原因があります
が 無明はいつ始めたか
そこだけはもういい加減は成り立ちませんよと
いう人類の中で究極な哲学なんです
ですから 本性はどうなっているのかと
輪廻の無限論に達すと
それは苦しみの限りのない回転を意味しますので
性悪説に傾いているようです
仏教は は無明渇愛という心の汚れに視点が成り成立できないとするならば
心の本性は悪だと決めなくてはならなくなっちゃいます
しかし 無限という時間因子を配慮するならば
決定することは極論で間違いということになります
はじめもないんだから
こんな決定することはできないんだと
次に無明は悪かと調べてみましょう
知らない 知らない 知られないということは悪だ
罪だというのは厳しいでしょ
特に子供たちが何かやったら
まあ我々悪だと思わないでしょ
知らないんだから 子供は
アヴィッジャービクエプッバンガマークサラナンダンマナンサンパッティサマパッティアアンワデーヴァアヒリカナント
これすごくいい言葉なんです
お釈迦様の 無明が不善に染まる
場合は前兆になりますと
ちょっと何か主語が抜けてますね
まあ無明は心が不善に染まる場合ですね
心が汚れてしまう場合は
無明ということは前兆になるんです
しかし 慚愧を除くという
これ今わからないんで
それから説明します  今文章を直しました
心が不善に染まる場合は無明が前兆になります
しかし 慚愧を除くということは
慚愧がある場合はあまり染めません
無明があるから不善 悪行為をするようになるのです
無明が不善の畑です 無明っていうのは畑です
この畑で不善が出てくるんです
悪が豊作になるから 無明という畑のせいだと断言できますかと私は聞きたいんです
あの畑で毒キノコ あるいはもう毒の植物たくさん入ってますよと
畑が悪いと言える 畑に栄養があるんだから
もう植物がもう豊作になっただけで
その豊作が毒かどうか
だからといって畑が悪いと畑いじめたって意味がないでしょうに
お釈迦様が言うのは この悪が起こす畑が無明であると
慚愧ってなんですかね
慚っていうのは悪い行為を恥じる気持ちなんです
愧っていうのは悪い行為を怖がる気持ちなんですね
だから恥じる気持ち 怖がる気持ちあったら
たとえ無明であっても悪いことしないんです
皆様も万引きしないのは
恥ずかしいか怖いかどちらかなんです
品物が欲しいだけでは万引きしません
怖いんです だからこの慚愧で自分たちを守られています
無明は待ってはいるんだけど
悪いことをやってやろうかなとかできなくなっちゃうんですね
無明が悪いことをさせますが
慚愧が割り込むとできなくなるんです
一般の人の心はその状況なんです
捏造論の立場からね これはずっと言っていることだから省略します
認識過程には必ず捏造してから知るというようなプログラムミスがあります
認識過程で捏造しちゃうんですね
認識が起きて知ることをしますが
残念ながらそれが愚痴なのです
承知ではありません 我々は何を認識しても
すべてまとめて愚痴なんです
プログラムにちょっとしたミスがあるんです
捏造するという 明確にすると
それは欠陥であり 改良しなくてはいけない状態なんです
プログラムを直せばいいんです
心の誤作動によって心の本性は悪だと断言できませんよ
機械に故障があって機械がうまくいかないならば
この機械が悪いんだと誰が言うんですかね
この故障直しちゃえばいいでしょうに
ですから 現実を見ることにしましょう
論理 理屈 宗教の話 経常学的な説明などは要らない
妄想で原罪などの神話概念も要らない
心理学者と同じく現状を分析して治療することが非個的な態度です
だから我々は善戦説も性悪説も勝手にしろよと
捨ててください どんなのは
現実を見てください 自分の現実の心を
心理学者と同じく分析して
今私の心は何なのですか？と
今の心は怒り 怒りだったらさっさと直してください
今の心はもう落ち込みだったら
さっさとそれを修理して直してください
それで話が終わりです
悪なら変える 善なら完成に励む
終了ということでやるべき態度は
はい これでまあちょっと余談なんですけど
余談にはまあ時間はないんですけど
えーと まあ余談だから気楽に読んでください
矛盾だらけの世論 人は原罪である
よく言いますね ユダヤ教
キリスト教 イスラム教は
ならば創造した神が犯人で
人間には関係がありません
だって人間作ったのは神でしょ
人間には問題があったら作ったやつが悪いでしょうに
欠陥品を創造する神が全知全能ではないんです
だから神は全知全能だと言えませんね
これ考えなかったんだからね
自分が作った人間が罪を犯すだろうと
大いに罪を犯しちゃえばいいんです
だから 原罪論が正しければ
大いに罪を犯して生活すればいいんです
だからわかりますね ちょっと理性で見ると
何言ってるのかと 頭がイカれて以外何でもないでしょ
ローマ教皇はじめみんな
しかし 罪を犯すたびに生きることは不幸になるんですね
ローマ教会いようかいなかろうが
イエスがいようかいなかろうが関係なく
悪いことするたびにやっぱりまずいでしょうに
神父の前で私は罪を犯しましたと見覚えのない罪を懺悔するのは愚かな行為です
自分 皆様よりも罪を犯している神父の前で隠れてね
私はもう罪を犯しましたとかね
あれで罪が消えると思ってるんですかね
そう思ったらそれ自体邪見でしょ
矛盾だらけの世論で 一切の生命に仏性がありという
極限に褒められた気分ですね
大乗仏教でよく言いますね
みんなに仏性仏性があるんだと
だから禅のあるお坊さんが
だから犬にも仏性あるのかと聞いた質問も専門でもあります
少々待ちと なぜ生きることは苦ですかね
仏性なら仏性と言いながら仏教の話ですね
生きることは苦でしょうに
なぜ罪を犯したくなるんですかね
善行為を嫌になりますかね
本来仏性でしょ でも私が悪いことをしたいんだけど
良いことはしたくないでしょ
変な仏性ですね それって仏性ですかね
仏性とは悪そのものですかね
だからいい加減なことを言ってるんです
偉大なる大乗仏教で 人は本来悟っているという本覚思想
世界はアホばかりで溢れていますが
学者は見当たりませんね
現実的にはどう見たってもね
私もはじめアホばっかしなんですね
悟ってる人ってなかなか
生まれた時悟ってきて
生まれて人がいる？誰一人も
無駄な修行をする坊さんは頭がイカれているか
苦しみの応援かどちらかでしょう
この本覚思想を喋っているこの天台宗とかは
お坊さんたちは真面目に修行してますよ
私よりは真面目ですけど
私は朝から晩までいい加減ですけど
もう結構真面目に修行してます
彼らは頭がイカれているか
なんて言ったっけ？苦しみの応援歌かどちらかなんです
やっぱり苦しみましょうと修行する必要ないんです
本学 本学ですね もう本来悟ってます
だから苦しみが好きだから修行してるんですという話になるんです
だから矛盾もいいところなんです
それが問題 矛盾だと思って
道元禅師が中国に行ってみたんですね
答えは見つかるために
自分の教理に対する反逆者ですかね
この人々は だって 本覚思想
本覚思想と言い張ったりしながら修行をするんですね
だから自分の宗教に対する反逆者なんですね
何ですかね こういう思考っていうのは
よくあること 世の中で
私が私になりたというような
とうとう反復論なんですね
これっていうのは 本学思想の反復論以外なんともないんです
それから一般的に言う清廉潔白は何なのかと
人は 生命は 心は 清廉潔白で説明するとは
希望的観察か現実を無視するかですね
あるいは希望的観察ですね
あるいは現実を無視して頭だけで考えているんです
その人々は現実的にある悪をどのように理解するのですかね
清廉潔白を語ると 現実的な悪の説明できないでしょう
清廉潔白が正しければ
悪を犯しても心は汚れないでしょう
心は清廉潔白だったら悪を犯しても大丈夫です
心は汚れません 大丈夫
だから大いに悪を犯してください
清廉潔白を信仰するならば
危険な非道徳論になります
だから清廉潔白っていうのは危険な非道徳論なんです
で 制約説 本性は悪であるならば
真理を知る意味も起こりません
興味も起こりません まあ心は本来悪だったらね
いいことをしようかとか気持ちも起こりませんよ
説法でも聞こうかなとか
全然その気は起こりません
根元から悪だったらね
でも世の中いるでしょうに
説法も聞きたくなるし
本も読みたくなるし もうね
いろいろ頑張りたくなる人もいるでしょうに
悪を犯しても文句を言ってはならないんです
批判してはならないんです
人々は人を殺したり 惨虐教育をやったり
殺戮をやったりしたっても批判するなよと
だって本来悪だからしょうがないでしょ
何人殺しちゃっても 善人になるようにと躾をしても
それは無駄な努力です
本来 悪の人が善人になろうと無理でしょうに
例えば泥と のも何かを金に磨いて磨いて金にするそうと
ありえないでしょ 泥だから
もともとは いくらやっても泥は泥なんです
ですから 危険な非道徳論なんです
聖善説とも聖悪説とも矛盾だらけで非道徳なんです
本覚思想も仏性論も非道徳なんです
邪見そのものです だから今日はそこはあまり今日の講演に使わなかったんです
最後にちょこちょこと言っただけで
バカバカらしくて で 結論
命 生命 人などなどを 言っても変わらない個体として一定した存在ではありません
というと変わるものなんです
そんなのは 人の性質は瞬間的に変わってしまうんです
変わる過程は止まらないんです
因果法則を理解して より幸福な生き方をするために
さらに輪廻を脱出するために努力してはならないのに
という これが最終的な答えなんです
良い人間になろうではないかということで忙しいでしょうに
皆様は 余計なことを考えてる暇がないんです
努力しては 努力しなくては
解脱するために努力しなくてはならないのにと
で 我々には我々は忙しいという結論で
生命は忙しくなるべきであるということで
それは仏教の立場なんですね
これで話は終了です はい
どうもありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生ありがとうございました
今日はちょっと会場の関係で九時で切りさせていただきたいので
少しおとの時間を割愛させていただきます
あの入り口の方で配ったと思うんですけど
七月になりましたらまた瞑想会などございますので
そちらの方でまた質問などしていただければと思います
では 最後に回向の文を皆さんに向かってお読みしたいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨ ヴィワッジャントゥサッバ ローゴー ヴィナッサトゥマーケー バワット アンタラーヨ スキーディーガー ユコー バワ
バワトゥ サッバ マングラン ラッカントゥ サッバ デワタ サッバ ブンターヌ ターヴェーナ サッバ ダンマー
ヌ ターヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌ ターヴェーナ
サダー スッティー バワントゥ テーアビ ワダン シーリス ニッチャン ワッダ パチャヤーナ
チャッターロー ダンマ ワッダンティヤーユ ワンノウ スカン バラン
サーデュサーデュサーデュ
はい ありがとうございます